what happens after humans screw up the
planet so bad it becomes uninhabitable
we pack up and go to space at least
that's the case in the new sci-fi epic
interstellar this was a treasure there's
been telling to leave for a while now oh
so deep Matthew but could McConaughey's
journey through a wormhole to save
humanity by finding us a new place to
live somewhere else in the galaxy really
happen well there's a whole commercial
space industry that seems to think so
and they're trying to do a humans do
best conquer colonize and make lots of
money Muslim will establish human
settlement on Mars in 2023 Mars one is a
company that is handing out one way
tickets for folks to go to bars set up a
human colony and never return sounds
like sci-fi but this is the real deal
it's been paying the space cowboy I am
applying to go to Mars that's just one
of the 200,000 people who applied for
the ride that starting in 2024 will send
for people to Mars every two years and
it's gonna cost billions so how exactly
are they going to finance it we will
finance this mission by creating the
biggest media event ever around it he's
talking about a giant reality TV show
kind of like The Hunger Games minus the
killing hopefully but even if these
would be reality TV stars make it to
Mars to pick up rocks that
have been picked up before they most
likely died within sixty eight days
according to MIT researchers some of the
other mostly billionaire funded
companies with space balls are moon
Express that wants to mine the moon for
resources then you have space tourism
offered by elon musk SpaceX and sir
richard branson's virgin galactic which
had a major setback when its test flight
for spaceship to crashed and killed one
of the pilots assuming it does go on
you'd have to dish out two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars just for a ride
but back to interstellar everyone and
their mom is so excited about the movie
that NASA was forced to issue a
statement saying we won't be setting up
earth to point o anytime soon the space
agency hasn't found any wormholes yet or
planets with living conditions would be
comfortable with and even if they did
exist real NASA technology hasn't caught
up with the Hollywood fantasy of warp or
even ludicrous speed to get us there so
far only one NASA space ship has almost
made it out of the solar system the
Voyager 1 it was launched in 1977 and
didn't reach interstellar space the
region between the stars and past Pluto
until 2012 so we really don't know how
long it'll be is where we can migrate to
Mars or mine the moon or take joy rides
in space but we do know that the clock
is ticking for planet Earth so here's a
question what if our space funds and
ambitions were funneled into fighting
climate change and making the earth more
livable rather than ditching it for
another planet could one small step for
multi-billionaires be a giant leap for
mankind or is the fate of humanity
better left in matthew mcconaughey's
hands
want more download the aj+ mobile app
and join the conversation available in
your app store now